you must obey the rules
on social
distancing the messages were clear stay
at home don't mix with others and yet
while the uk was forced indoors into
lockdown boris johnson and his staff
were breaking those laws and attending
parties and other gatherings partygate
as it was called was splashed across the
front pages
two downing street parties were held on
the eve of the funeral of prince philip
the duke of edinburgh with the country
in national mourning and queen elizabeth
forced to sit apart from her family
now after months of denials the prime
minister has been forced to admit he
broke the law i understand the anger
that many will feel that i myself fell
short when it came to observing the very
rules which the government i lead had
introduced to protect
the public
and i accept in all sincerity that
people had the right to expect better
and not just the prime minister rishi
sunak the uk chancellor who also lives
in downing street has been issued with a
police fine as well and the police
investigations are ongoing more fines
could follow
at the heart of the anger over this
scandal is the fact that in the height
of the pandemic the british public were
legally prevented from gathering
together
from burying loved ones even from
attending weddings while at the same
time the people responsible for those
legal rules here in downing street were
having bring your own booze parties and
organizing leaving do's for departing
staff some of which were attended by the
prime minister and the chancellor boris
johnson has always said that nobody told
him that these gatherings were against
the rules but it's that excuse that
calls into question his judgment his
character and his credibility
this is the first time in the history of
our country that a prime minister's been
found to be in breach of the law
and then he lied repeatedly to the
public about it
britain deserves better
they have to go
but to depose the prime minister at
least 54 mps from his own conservative
party have to trigger a vote of no
confidence and with the ukraine war
still raging even johnson's fiercest
critics are uneasy with the timing
the prime minister faces a very serious
situation which the house of commons is
going to have to deal with
because patiently he has misled the
house
but that's that we're in the middle of
an international crisis
and now is absolutely not the time
to destabilize the government
a government that's actually leading the
international coalition against putin
those conservative mps who have the
power to oust him will return to
parliament next week and they have
between now and then to weigh up their
appetite for calling the removal trucks
paul brennan al jazeera downing street